[Música]
[Aplausos]
la decisión
los veamos a mucha gente
[Música]
en el pensamiento de mayo
lo mismo
como lo llamamos
en la parte de atrás saliendo las tartas
eso me va a acompañar
entonces
y
sean normales del ambiente
pero por favor
por favor
i
a poner tu nombre
ahora tu carta es la junta de firmas y
vamos a dar la vuelta y la vamos a
doblar
por favor esa carta y las bandejas al
horno
y vamos a hacer lo mismo vamos a tomar
una carta en este caso el 7 de diamantes
este
con comino si aparte también una caridad
él simplemente es con mi firma jd picas
conducir
en esta ciudad y en cuatro pedazos y la
vamos a poner equivoca
hace lo mismo que yo hago
[Música]
tengo 14 años ya estaba viendo cómo
funciona esto
[Música]
lo mismo
alrededor y hasta ahora que me entiendo
como ahora yo tengo la carta de ella
hasta el momento
las decisiones y como cuando haces una
mezcla de las cartas todos tenemos las
cartas de que es una mezcla esto es
sencillo
luego se hace
ahora como hacemos un corte con cuatro
cajas es sencillo levantamos una dos
tres o cuatro cartas la levantamos de
arriba
uno dos tres
de esta forma si hacemos esto
de esta manera
[Música]
desde el centro y vamos a dar
por la mitad
para tener dos semanas sus manos
ponerlas hacia arriba y uno de los
montones lo ponen encima de otros
sencilla lo hemos hecho todos
esta mañana en el transcurso de la
semana ya sea en el amor en el dinero
[Música]
uno dos tres cuatro de arriba abajo
diferentes y cortamos ya vamos a hacer
una especie de abanico
[Música]
tres trocitos de arriba arriba
siempre tomamos de arriba y lo ponemos
al vídeo es matemático
[Música]
una dos o tres cartas en la parte de
arriba una dos o tres dos o tres horas
de verdad
ahora es una persona de su derecha
y esa que recibe la media
si no tiene nada para cambiar o corregir
ante masa es matemático
una semana tenemos que hacer semana que
la de arriba y decimos lunes la vía día
lo ponemos a los tipos martes la de
arriba abajo miércoles jueves viernes
el mundo
[Música]
no me quiere la ponen abajo no me quiere
la lanzan me quieren la ponen abajo no
me quiere la lanza y así siguen me
quiere no me quiera hasta que nos
quedemos con una carta todos tenemos una
carta la levantan por favor todos todos
todos todos ahora tuvimos el vital de la
suerte tuvimos el vital del amor ahora
no funciona con todos pero si tenemos
suerte esta semana con el dinero
en el bolsillo
[Música]
ambos pedazos
d
del mismo
[Aplausos]
[Música]